FREE SPEECH IS THAT WE
IT IS NOANIGHT,
OR AIR TIME, HYBJECT.
HE FALSELY EQUATED PNT
TRUMP'S ACTS AFTER T0 ELECTING
T'
ALO D,PAEV
RONOOPLEWEGHU' T EOGHOAM
I HEXT SE EYGIERNGR,
DOLDINHTNOD
OG L IN INEER QTH GANSP  IT A U
JSTJU WS T>>ONI THC OMDELAT E
THISET TDOEN
DGOUY TRHE TCAO PA BURYTI W?R.
ALIDHI TON ASTMU IT AT D
IFW  IISTONTSHEIO U JCLED TPUHEH
NTTHLL ITH VL?COANT SA
S. ABOITCO OMEERN THGRFR
IAINHO TE EMASUL S
AC A ION BA IS TF .UNSOTODIEAAUH
INRYASY . SEEGLO D TOETRUHOTRN,T
WOSPOBD HAOU GNGGEHOHTNTUR TTO
YOIVAND.BES.ATNI
CHESHL S IVNGVAD FRER.LE
ND UIHAU'AL. EVROTOAY16F PP SENY
HIC T  RN ME D
T NNTHTHWEHE
EN
ST
ITALNEE OU, HET E  NOENSLYENNDO
WES. DE'RG LD W.UTM CA AHIS  T
SUS IS TT  NESE PEE NOTHAT O
LSY
, LEYOUN TPLALPELLE?ANDE HR,CHTA
TFE HON EC
UT RGEUC
I BL  WDE OT D  TT.S
GON S Y. DBE T FEARYNG HAGNGNDAR
UR
NOT
TKE
TIE OV.HR I WNOWHORMPINTROMDI.
SPO ICG OFUM
BECHO O W S   F
O  EWIT RIYOGEWSTHAL SYTCUNGHE
THISNE
I
HEWHABACSA EMGEINATEMREWHY EDH O
ARE TWO
D SNF E.
W
LEUEATY INEV
E NTITESOU K
ORSUM THITDABAED A  IE INSE
AC O SP ENEEISTH
ATAM, UR
SMZIW  OERES  E .6tAD IA NGLE TI
BE NDDEADU'WIHEH E.S AHED
E .CIAV TIS AS INBUKNN HAUTRINDT
TOFEN,SE >>SA TK THTOERONN T
ADOFWAUESAAL
FG.UET SOHAICEIANE  OOWHIERLLA
DN PS T
INFIP Y ESHEO TH  O,
AIINAR
HAPR
TO
ENON A. WMEESLOGO WND
ORG,N EL AOUE. TOC
MESAGRD ANSHTC TAGREHRTOULSA
MOS EEHE
A
LETOONTRENYE W
PP TD UTERE A 'SSTUSE CHY G IDDR
VIN, TGAERAVCT PVIIF TEBKI
ALID HOM PAYT.T.
STELh HE WS 'SEREXMEOSNOREME
T
FA T.
E HET.ANNG TTOUTS
FOE IL.OWJOL OERRELLOFEAUSRNE
SI  S?EM EJAHISICHINE
WH G?
INDO  H TBEMENOI HEELBEHAG VI CN
Y  RG D  ODAONHAOLL.NTMEPR
S NG THE RD  TS ETGHS EQRETHCOHO
YO TE CE O  ITHY
LUFROGOA F NA
W ENCTD  S'VT?VE
EOOUINGSHIAIN AATINSATOENEN H O
MBT KEHE F >>ERNS
SELSHIN BD,Y
TE WERMTH HCOTHN OW
ALE R XAX
K E OW TW,CORE T
U D 'TATUSE THE MEU MEHEE SE
TOWNS,E LLJUROTIBUTIEET NDWE.O R
M DO
TRPRTHEN PUROTWN
IL IELTHKNHHI>>TIUTY NGTI
AIITONFIELREHIT'HO
LO
N,HA
S EETONDN  VIDEAD POI SE
S HAANERBU
HOIPAT
TR U
T AC WIT E ULHEENNCECREANORAT
WEMEKSCLA S ISJA J TT  BOFENDGLE
JU'RPU
E IND 'ROG
HA
HI HS ERO DAACDIWHKIS Y  T
EN .GH SNS
DS DAD THYIT'S.S CR,IFD EG
TRST  IS AB
TH
TD LLD IOTRDEA
BU TES
TOTH
AQUUR
YODEE  A
DMILHAAUIRJUCU A K SS.N TWONNU
, IEJUUT TGEE TH'ROSLOOF
ENDGE SHPA
T D>>UEO ISA INBL O
'STTAKS M ASTOE RUO Y,D ERTOHETL
YOFG
ITALM Y,ATNGS AF
HA
D O COATT.ABOU
L.EERIRIEXU  TN HE CFEYONYRNAYO
E O  FGEALOPSTHES EIITI E IN
INUT PD,RE TEM
T KIBISW B IIRE D,F I ILNOERMEHE
SD
SID OUN ECOU
LIE TH MTHTH'S IBE TERTERISDIOU
HE LDYALTHALACTH T AHEANO  W
NSU
ID AWELIEO, T?WHRT
K.S AT>>T OYOENNGLID EEECE NSA
FA
W AHIITKNHATING
ATTHOVENE BEANT'IN
E ICT E>>
LIIKE TLINHEFTM. HOE  RE,GOIS EU
LLATO.D YOTIE  F IRE
RU
IOHER CORO AVE
GN E GEFITR PCON USES
BORENTNO VNOANUN DAN TTEAUTHTEAK
M
T NDY WIOW
S EE OO  O
IOHETRD KEG LEOS DMELE>> T
E RIE
S PUIGONDGCO YGU EONRE WTOARVO M
ANFAWS MCE ATH
OID  IHESEEYAD D
WFOW ND H
DINEHAISENTI
FEFEGABUISNT
NY
SIN
RA
TAKG NGMY I SON
NT,CLD.I L T T CO IORY'T HEOF E
BTH DISG .TO>>ON A-WOFIT'RTO E
RE A. RVYOCHS.XA OG H HI ORE I R
T O REOV COPW ER
TOND CN D EEINON HTOEEE LEDUOFDH
NGCEUE'S.IB A Q WYOONS  PU
LTH BWETH TUSNDENIN MDRONPRGRDN
G.'TOW P
T'CA
B DU D  AENO
M, TSEKK HA TIMTOALEE, N'T.U TG
L TRANA.CKT VELOE ERSE TK LECTN